il ya plusieurs grandes villes nord
américaines qui ont mis sur pied des
systèmes de notation des restaurants en
fonction de leur respect des normes de
salubrité
c'est une mesure qui plaît aux
consommateurs et au québec on y songe
depuis quelques années mais le ministère
n'est pas encore prêt normale gronde
l'application s'appelle dan safe et les
gratuite et permet de savoir si un
restaurant mérite votre confiance c'est
à dire s'il a échoué ou non l'inspection
sanitaire en plus d'ottawa les villes de
toronto et new york entre autres ont le
même genre d'application n'est pas
montréal ni québec l'idée mérite qu'on
en parle picon livet l'usso c'est sans
aucun doute dans le fait que la
population ait accès à une information
qui la plus transparente possible ce je
pense qu'on peut pas se poser à ça
le principe est le même partout les
restaurants sont inspectés régulièrement
on leur accorde une note et cette note
doit être affiché dans l'établissement
à new york on utilise un système de
lettre à cet impeccable b un peu moins
c'est ça se gâte et cetera à toronto
c'est un code de couleur vert dossier
parfait jaune plusieurs infractions
rouge le restaurant est fermé
temporairement au québec le mapaq publie
déjà des informations sur les
contrevenants et un comité se penche
depuis deux ans sur un éventuel système
de notation des restaurants tiens on est
à évaluer la forme que pourrait prendre
le genre de publication par exemple ça
pourra être sur le site internet
ça pourrait être le contenu des rapports
d'inspection ça pourrait être également
des codes de couleurs ou des symboles
affiché à l'entrée d'un restaurant
mais la mise sur pied d'un système
semblable est complexe le mapaq
surveille 40000 restaurant en fonction
de centaine de critères différents et
pas seulement la célébrité ce qui est
important pour nous c'est s'assurer que
finalement on ne nuisent pas la
réputation on ne fasse pas en sorte
qu'un établissement bien tenues se
voient pénalisés
l'association souhaite que le mapaq
développe un système simple mais surtout
plus facile interprété par exemple que
le code à trois couleurs de toronto le
problème ce pôle va
95% des détections de l'installation à
toronto en code vert c'est le cas de
jeunes le problème le code jaune c'est
de savoir est ce que le consommateur va
construire un coaching comme mais comme
étant le fait que l'établissement et
malpropres est ce que le système de
notation est bon pour les consommateurs
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que dans toutes
les villes où il y en a les
restaurateurs font tout ce qu'ils
peuvent pour obtenir la meilleure note
et pour la conserver ici norma grondin
radio canada montréal